et si l'ordinateur était un bel
objet quelque chose que vous voulez regarder et
avoir chez vous et si au lieu
d'être entre de bonnes mains, il était
entre les mains de tout le monde, nous parlerions
du changement le plus tectonique du statu
quo et  centre, je vous supplie de gérer les
attentes si je vous ai déjà laissé tomber à
chaque [ __ ] de fois, alors je vais faire
votre action Apple vaut 441 millions de
dollars et votre fille et sa mère
bénéficient de l'aide sociale, elle n'est pas ma fille, vous
devez pouvoir  vois qu'elle
te ressemble nous saurons bien assez tôt si tu étais
Léonard de Vinci ou si tu penses que
tu l'es tu es le seul à voir le monde de la
même manière que moi personne ne voit le monde de la
même manière que tout le monde attend
le magazine qu'est-ce que les gens vont en
faire c'est un résumé tu vas faire que
tu donnes des
instructions contradictoires tu es insubordonné rendre les
gens misérables la fuite du conseil tu
n'es plus nécessaire à cette entreprise je
me suis assis dans le garage et  a inventé le
fu  ture parce que les artistes dirigent et les hacks
demandent un vote à main levée ce que vous faites
n'est pas censé être la meilleure partie de
vous quand vous êtes un père c'est ce qui est
censé être la meilleure partie de vous Je suis
le seul qui sait  que ce gars est
quelqu'un que vous avez
inventé y a-t-il un plan que le plan vous proposera
lorsque vous serez prêt à le voir
se produire regardez le retour d'un
co-fondateur de superstar Steven jobs CJ un
travail soigné revient à Apple
deux événements les plus importants de  le 20ème
siècle maintenant tous les yeux gagnent la guerre et
cela